Film Courage: How does a writer know if prose
is better for them creatively
or the screenwriting format?
Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher:
I think it's just trial and error.
I wrote a screenplay in 2019 right before covid
and I was jazzed about it and I'm like let's go
let's go and I wasn't ready to show it yet but
I knew that I had because I knew I had rewrites
to do and then now I'm writing the novel so I
read the characters are intriguing me so much
I'm like I really need to get in their heads
and I real and and when I write I hand write I
I'm not a typer so I have to handwrite everything
and that's and that's giving me so much joy right
now because that's just like I'm finding out
things about the theme and what I thought I was
presenting and I was just like oh no that's not
the theme at all so it's yeah it if something's
a screenplay or a book it could be both it's and
it could be just a novel and some novels would be
really hard to adapt I but I think I would like
to think in myself if anyone asked me to adapt a
novel that was unadaptable I feel like I could
find the thread to do it but that's probably
because I get a little delusional and I want to
problem solved so so you love these characters
so much that you realized that 110 page whatever
screenplay wasn't wasn't enough for you creatively
yeah I think yeah I don't know if it wasn't enough
I think there's I don't think the screenplay is
there yet so that's part of it and I think
there's a lot more to explore and for me the
way to explore it is through pros and I'm just
doing it that way and in the end it might be a
graphic novel who knows I it's almost like you
don't want to you don't want to put it in a ball
too quick let's just let the story go let's
let's see where this story goes and who who
knows it maybe it is just a book maybe maybe
it never was meant to be on the screen at all
or maybe the book gets tossed away and I learn a
couple things and go back in the rewrite I don't
think we should I don't think we should hold
on to the the medium so much that work through
it and try to complete things but we shouldn't
we I don't think we need to give the medium so
much power let's give the story The Power was
there a defining book of your teenage years
so I really couldn't read books in my teenage
years because I grew up the Jehovah's Witness
and I was reading more bible stuff and the
and only slid by in the books that were
that were assigned to us in school so
and they essentially were like just
try to read enough so you can get by and
get a decent grade and get out it was it
was very discouraged to read anything that
wasn't published by the Jehovah's Witnesses
when so when so what happened was a friend of mine
a friend of mine in the Jehovah's Witnesses was
disfellowshipped so he was shunned and then he
killed himself and so I went to the elders and I
was looking for help and because I was because I'm
like wait Gibby killed himself and how can I not
kill myself because I do have suicide in my family
that's not related to the Jehovah's Witnesses so
they were completely unhelpful they
didn't want me to grieve his suicide
they just said make sure you keep going and
preaching and stay and that was not the answer
for me so what I did and this is I think I was
22 or 23. I went to the library instead and I
went to the psychology section and I'm like
where do I get help so I found Tony Robbins
and I found a Wayne Dyer oh yeah and I would
just sit there in the stacks and read these
and it kind of gave me a little bit of perspective
and then it was next to poetry and I started and
I just started opening poetry books and I was and
I was just and they were speaking to me and then
somehow the first novel I read was Giovanni's Room
[James Baldwin] so I read that book kind of didn't
get it because it's a homosexual love affair if
I remember right I haven't read it since then
but I got the I got the heart of it it meant
something to me and I was like who do I read
next so James Baldwin was my number one and then I
read Henry Miller and then I found out that there
was this guy Jack Kerouac who was who wrote on
the road and it was the Beat Generation I'm like
what's a beat and I remember skateboarding to
the library before it closed because I had to
get a copy of On The Road that weekend and
read it and I read that and I went and these
were touching me on emotional levels it was I
was having a conversation with authors that had
died but they were but they were I was having a
conversation that I never got to have in my life
and that that's what changed everything and then
I read a book called hunger by Knut Hamsun this
Norwegian author and that's when I went I'm
a writer that was the book where I just went
that's it I'm a writer and I'm going full in and
even if I can't eat and I have to die I'm writing
till the end so and when did you tell family
people in the church that you were a writer
well I was still married and I was married so I
ended up getting married to a Jehovah's Witness
and I was still married I told her that out
and she begged me not to tell anyone and I
didn't and that was very codependent of me but
I was also I was also unhealthy at the time as
well but I was writing at the time and I was
and I started a thing called film junkie and
and I would go to film festivals I knew all of
a sudden I was a journalist in 1999 I was like
this is all you got to do so I was going to
these see all these movies before they were
raided because you can't watch rated R movies in
the Jehovah's Witnesses and then I was writing
about all these movies and then but then they
would come out and be rated R and they'd be
like how did Tony see that and they're like well
it wasn't rated yet and they'd be like oh okay
when I was kind of out of the out of it so
I was actively like writing and working on
my own stuff and it was starting to get seen
around and people would get in touch with my
wife at the time and be like Tony's kind of you
wrote something that didn't seem a little too
Christian maybe you should talk to him about it
and then I would lean in harder and write a sex
scene so because I was being very contrarian at
the time and I think I needed essentially I was
getting my teenage angst out when I was 27 which
is just totally embarrassing you need to get it
out in your teen years but it was a little later
for me so then you moved to LA and you felt like
that you could be your own person and and that
you didn't feel shame about writing anything
oh I feel shame about writing everything no I
did the LA move didn't happen for a long time I
stayed in San Francisco I was writing for the San
Francisco Chronicle so I was covering books and
music for the chronicle and I wasn't planning
on moving to Los Angeles and then I finished
[Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk] and then I
was shopping it around I got an agent and then I
got a publisher and then so that the book came
out and then the option thing started happening
where things go to die so so but it but it
was beautiful I got to work with producer
who runs Hunting Lane films Jamie Patrickoff
and we worked on the pitch for the TV series
and and I learned so much about like writing
pitches taking notes and he was very gracious
with me and and then it was just like that kind
of just fizzled out there there's like meh no
screw it and I don't think it was him I think it
was the people that he had interested and then
and then the book got to Eric Stoltz and then
that's when he he said hey let's first off I found
out Eric Stoltz was reading my book and I was just
like well I could just die now we're done and then
yeah and then then he said we need Tony to write
the screenplay so we don't lose the voice and I
went and I went challenge taken so I yeah I worked
on that really hard and hours and hours on end
and so I wasn't oh so I wasn't in LA yet I was I
was in San Francisco and he was he's in New York
so we were doing a lot of back and forth that
way and then as it went in it got delayed and
then shooting was supposed to start another time
it got delayed but I knew I had to be in LA for it
and so I just got down to LA when it was in
pre-production and I sublet my apartment in
San Francisco and I just would sublet around LA
while I was in pre-production and then and some
months later we were on set and on location so
that's how I came to LA I was already very far
out of the Jehovah's Witnesses I was already
divorced I was I had already created a writing
life in San Francisco and I was I knew it
was time to leave San Francisco but I was
kind of thinking New York because I was writing
for publications and going on that angle but
the nudge to LA brought me here which was it
turned out to be the right choice and yeah.